[Musique]
alors quand on m'a invité à faire une
réflexion sur l'amour l'amour en famille
je me suis dit est-ce qu'il faut que je
parle de l'amour maternel un vote
interne elle d'un amour filial de
l'amour fraternel de l'amour
transgénérationnel maintenant par les
normandes latran génération le rôle des
grands parents des
arrière-grands-parents de narnia et
grands parents bientôt on va parler des
dinosaures mais moi je me suis dit
est-ce que ça vaudrait pas la peine de
prendre tous ces amours là et puis
essayer de voir qu'ils sont lus news
dans la façon de dire l'amour
vous connaissez le je t'aime mais vous
me lisez aussi légitime bien vous
connaissez est-ce que tu m'aimes
vraiment un ou dis moi qui tu m'aimes
mais pourquoi tu veux que je te dise que
je t'aime que je t'ai les neiges a
brillé hier c'est à dire que il y a
quelque chose dans l'amour de l'amour
dit est dans le moule amour montrer et
moi je verrais aujourd'hui faire une
réflexion sur qu'est ce que c'est que
deux personnes n'ont même femme à maryse
n'épouse père en fils umair
un fils et sert à dalea bourdy et
l'amour montrer mes dires
on dirige utilisent la langue donc je
vous rappelle cette magnifique sur le
magnifique écrit des se développe dans
lequel ils disent dans lequel le maire
est redit à son esclave va me chercher
la meilleure des choses au marché et ils
reviennent avec une langue
il a dit c'est la langue la meilleure
des choses parce que c'est la langue de
l'amour de la poésie et ses outils de la
langue
je ne vais pas vous donner ça à mes
invités va aller me chercher le plat
pire des choses
alors il va marcher et ils reviennent
avec la langue dix ans c'est la pire des
choses la source de guerre de la
calomnie du mensonge etc
c'est à dire que la langue d'expression
par la langue ça peut être très beau
mais ça peut être très moche et
j'aimerais évoquer ces messieurs c'est
peut-être beaucoup d'entre vous vous
connaissez c'est monsieur martin buber
c'est un philosophe tons de brun qui a
dit que dans la relation entre deux
personnes
il ya des modes de ces relationnel
il ya d'abord la relation je tue ou
l'autre est un sujet et il ya la
relation jeu ça où l'on traite un objet
c'est à dire que le jeu tu l'autre
pourra dire aussi jeu et moi je suis
anti c'est à dire que il y à une sorte
de réciprocité dans la relation une
réciprocité amoureuse une réciprocité
je dirais écologique parce que c'est la
maison tandis qu'elle allège sa l'autre
sans objet quand on dit tu es
ma moitié d'orange l'autre ce quoi c'est
un objet ou c'est un sujet et c'est là
où je pense que c'est intéressant de
dire que ce seulement le jeu tu oui il
ya les tic relationnel
si nous arrivons par le travail que je
fais des thérapeutes à transformer la
relation amoureuse j'ai ça on se tue on
a bien réussi le boulot martin buber a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle je te tue
qui est un peu un petit livre qui est
facile à lire mais qui a trait qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est à dire que
moi j'aimerais soulever
quel amour en grand c'est l'amour
d'allah relation je tue ou l'autre
existe comme disait levinas l'autre mais
montre un visage et ses visages que je
respecte
l'emprise déguisé en amour avec petites
lettres dans la relation jeu ça c'est
mon pain quotidien
du point de vue de mon travail c'est à
dire que très souvent on vient nous
consulter on vient en consultation des
familles avec des problématiques que je
n'irai des des relations j'ai ça va te
laver les dents il est temps qu où il
est à sa leaf toi tu vas arriver en
retard à l'école c'est un cul océan ça
et je crois que si nous voulons parler
amour la partie pédagogique parce qu'on
se doit de faire laver les dents au
monde sinon ces ruines avec deux
dentistes
il faut qu'ils aillent à l'école sinon
un examen
2 je pense que c'est très important que
dans la relation parent enfant l'enfant
se sent exister
quels enfants sentent qu'ils puissent
qu'on aime la partie pédagogique est en
train d'éclipser la partie est affective
jeu mais que j'aurais plus loin jeudi on
peut tisser l'éducation sur un canevas
d'amour un canevas affectif
or aujourd'hui étant dans une société
qui est plutôt quantitative par
qualitatif on prend donne beaucoup plus
d'importance à la partie éducative que
les parties affective et ça m'arrive
très souvent de dire embrasser le quand
ils le méritent le moins pas c'est quand
il a le plus besoin c'est à dire que il
ya deux mots que je vous invite à
retenir ils sont un peu compliqué à
[Musique]
prononcer c'est la subjectivation c'est
à dire rendre l'autre sujet l'objectif
ication c'est rendre l'autre objet quand
une mère de famille dit il est 7 heures
s'est servi tout le monde à table
personne vire qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous
attendez une invitation personnelle oui
parce que c'est seulement quand je va
mais considérez moi individus que au jeu
pourra je pourrais venir
être autonome mais aujourd'hui on est en
train de demander à être autonome avant
de considérer l'autre comme un individu
donc attention à l'objectif ication
parce que l'objectif ication va tuer
l'amour
va cacher l'amour maintenant je mettrais
dire deux mots sur l'amour et la
culpabilité
il ya des gens qui sont coupables de
notre eau et d'autres qui sont coupables
de ne pas avoir aimé ac l'a de nouveau
ce sont des critères quantitatifs
complètement stupide
1 parce que on ne peut pas arriver trop
où l'on aimait trop peu on aime ça sort
d'ici et puis selon m
maintenant le problème et montrer
l'amour
combien de fois quand il ya une famille
à table quelqu'un va dire à l'autre
portait pas la tête là mais tu es là ton
com est là mais tu n'es pas là c'est à
dire que même des gens qui échangent
j'y passais famille de communiquer table
par téléphone portable où ils s'envoient
des sms de whatsapp à table entre les
différents membres de la famille ça
c'est une dynamique tout à fait 21e
siècle avril 2010 2019 mais montrer
montrer se rendre compte de ce qu'on le
dit qu est ce qu on dit avec les êtres
et pas seulement avec le faire parce que
là ya c'est que nous le thérapeute nous
appelons à livres de compte amoureux
c'est à dire on ya l'amour donné l'amour
a su ce que je fais pour toi ce que tu
fais pour moi ce que tu me donnes ce que
tu m'aimes
est-ce que je mets toi mais c'est un
livre de contes que d'ailleurs ils
s'appellent ledger s'arrêter
inventé l'idée par monsieur burns line
hadj qui est un grand thérapeute qui
habitait aux états unis 1
c'est à dire que très souvent on va
accumuler des mérites dans le faire
qu'en lettres amoureux va se refroidir
qu'est ce que je vais m arrêter là parce
que je vois que j'ai encore neuf minutes
alors je veux je vais faire un peu de
pressing
c'est à dire qu'il y a des gens qui
s'agitent qui font des choses et on
n'arrive pas à savoir qui ils sont par
exemple une mère de famille qui aime ses
enfants
mercredi après midi qui les amène au
foot à la danse à la flûte au violon
faire de la poterie etc
on est en train de faire mes caisses qui
on est et dans le fait d être
c'est vrai que on aimerait donner
beaucoup mais il ya des couples par
exemple qu'il faut énormément des sports
ensemble et ils ont un plaisir fou à
faire du sport ensemble mais ils parlent
pas est-ce que c'est complet il se
montre quelque chose on fait du sport
ensemble mais c'est l'amour de ski où
c'est l'amour de la bonne femme qui qui
est avec moi c'est à dire que le fait
d'émettre ensemble montrer et dire va
donner une image beaucoup plus complète
de ces que ce que j'entends pas l'amour
d'autre part l'amour peut être un outil
sentimentale stratégique ya ce que
j'appelle la manipulation amoureux la
manipulation amoureuse c'est le moment
où au nom de l'amour
on essaye donc de tirer la couverture à
soi
on perçoit à l'autre qui la choque c'est
à dire que c'est le moment c'est le
moment où dit on dit à son cher petit
thuir à la piscine lorsque tu seras
nager c'est le moment où de riscle et
dresse les voiles mais restent au port
des messages contradictoires qui vont
complètement polje la relation amoureuse
et où on perd la confiance parce que le
la base de la confiance à niveau
familial
c'est dans l'amour si on peut se confier
si on peut avoir confiance c'est que la
meilleure manière de montrer l'amour
ces manipulations amoureuse 1
que de temps en temps sa porte des
fruits à vous avez vu il ya trois jours
dans les journaux
tu es la femme des daubes eidos a obtenu
25% qu amazon de lors du divorce
quel investissement il fait face à six
mètres pendant un certain temps et
maintenant elle à 25% dans ma zone
est ce que c'est de la manipulation
amoureuse monsieur trump au cap il a
divorcé de madame 30 permanence remparts
et 400 millions de dollars et les deux
étaient très contents parce que
l'appartement des trous
c'est à dire est ce que c'est de la
manipulation amoureuse c'est de l'amour
qui s'éteint c'est quoi et c'est pour ça
que je crois que il est très important
de pouvoir soulever soulever et
j'aimerais terminer sur cette réflexion
attention pas trop d'éducation beaucoup
plus de relations affectives et
amoureuse
parce que on risque de prendre l'amour
en otage le vrai amour c'est rire
ensemble du fond du coeur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]